-My first guest is --
A lot of people
call him the best.
That's it. He's just the best.
Because he is.
He's an Emmy-
and Golden Globe-winning actor
who stars in the new movie
"Wild Mountain Thyme,"
which is in theaters
and on demand this Friday.
Here is the one and only
Jon Hamm!
Oh!
-You know what?
-That's what I'm talk--
-I'll take it.
-That's what I'm talking --
-It's great to see you, buddy,
as always.
-The best. This is the best.
-Yeah, no, I had to call you the
best, because you really are.
Everyone I talk to,
they go, "Please,
we love Jon Hamm. He's the --"
You are the best.
-I'll take it. I'll take it.
-Last time you were on our show,
we were talking to each other
from our homes.
It was seven months --
seven months ago.
-Early pandemic.
-Now I'm in the studio.
But you were back on a film set.
-By yourself.
I know. I was back on a film set
in Detroit, Michigan,
during the election.
-Wow.
-Which was very strange
to be in a battleground state
during an election,
I will say that.
But also strange making a movie
where everybody
has to be in masks
until three seconds before
they start rolling the cameras.
-Oh, my gosh.
-But we did it. We were safe.
Nobody got infected
or super-spread anything.
-Is this the Soderbergh movie?
-Steve Soderbergh directed.
-Come on.
-Cast including myself.
We had a Cheadle.
We had a Benicio del T.
-Oh.
-We had a Kieran Culkin.
-[ Stammering ]
-For the younger viewers
out there, we had a Noah Jupe.
-I would go to this party
in two seconds.
-Had it been not on lockdown,
you would have been invited.
-Oh, my gosh. Were you guys
in a bubble somewhere?
-Yeah, we all stayed in the same
hotel in downtown Detroit,
which by the way, Detroit,
if you get a chance, go visit.
It's a very cool city.
I'd never been. My first time.
And, yeah, it was super awesome.
-Oh, and they have great
hot dogs there, by the way.
-Yeah, the Coney dogs, man.
I definitely -- I visited
Lafayette Coney Dogs.
Free plug.
-Yeah, but I love
that there's two --
-And you know they're right next
to each other, exactly.
-Actually, the walls
are touching, the two --
American might be
the other one, right?
-Yeah, American and Lafayette,
they share a wall.
-[ Laughs ]
Competing Coney dogs.
-If you don't like hot dog here,
the exact same thing
is right next door.
-Three seconds away
is the exact same thing.
-Exactly. Just in case.
-It is not even Larry David.
It's beyond.
It's not a spite --
-No, it's not a spite store.
Or it might be a spite store,
but if it is,
it's going on for 70 years,
so it's amazing.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my gosh.
How is Cheadle doing?
-Great. In fact, I went
to Lafayette Coney Dogs
with Cheadle.
So it had to be
a pretty out-of-body experience
for the, like, Greek man,
who didn't care, by the way.
He was like, "How many hot dogs
do you want?"
We were like, "Two each."
[ Both laugh ]
-That was -- Yeah, that was
the highlight of --
He had no idea it was you guys.
Didn't care.
He's like, "Yeah, we're good."
-Selling dogs.
-Speaking of dogs,
you got a dog.
-I do. Where is he?
Oh, I think he's hiding.
But, yeah, it's --
We got a puppy.
And by pup-- I'm using that
very, very loosely,
because he goes about 65 pounds,
and he's 8 months old.
-Wait, how is he --
-He's going to be a chunk.
He's going to be a big chunk.
Let me see if I can actually --
-What kind of a dog?
Poodle?
-It's half -- Yeah.
Half Rottweiler.
-80-pound Poodle.
-Murphy.
[ Whistling, snapping fingers ]
Murphy, come.
-Uh-oh.
-Alright. You ready?
-Let me see this --
-This is Murphy.
-Ohh, it's a good puppy!
-Murphy!
-That's a puppy.
Hi, Murph!
[ Laughing ] Oh, my gosh.
He's a beast, dude.
He's going to be big.
-I'm not kidding.
I'm not kidding.
He is a large, large dog.
-Is this his TV debut?
-Yeah, it's his TV debut.
He immediately,
by the way, left.
-Yeah. Of course.
-He is exactly like the Greek
waiter at Lafayette Coney Dog.
Doesn't care.
-He's like,
"Yeah, Jimmy Fallon --"
-Got what he needed, came in,
got his toy, bailed.
-Yeah, out. Yeah.
-Peace out.
-You know what I wanted
to talk to you quickly about,
but we don't have to
lay on the horn too much.
But our buddy Andy Samberg
was on the show recently,
and we're talking, like,
"What shows you watching
during quarantine?"
And he goes, "You know
what I'm watching is 'Mad Men.'"
And I go, "What do you mean,
'Mad Men' with Hamm?"
He's like, "Yeah, I know.
That's our friend, Jon Ha--"
I go, "You've never seen it?"
He goes, "I know it, I've seen,
but I've never watched
the whole thing."
And he goes,
"I just feel so bad.
because I don't know if -- We
never really fake discussed it.
but he probably assumed that
I saw it, and I just never --"
He goes, "But it's amazing."
I go, "Of course it's amazing.
But it's like, he won Emmys.
We celebrated with him.
Dude, like --"
-Yeah. You know,
the funny thing was, like,
the first time I hosted "SNL,"
they all dressed up
in "Mad Men" gear,
like, everybody.
And I was like,
Samberg kind of half-assed it.
I was like, "What are you --
Who are you?
Like, you just put a tie on?
What's the deal?"
Everybody else -- Like,
Paula Pell taped a cigarette
to her thing and was in,
like, a little pencil skirt.
And Hader was in drag as Joan.
Like, everybody else
was sort of into it.
So I realized, like,
when Samberg --
He texted me
in like April or May.
And he's like,
"I got to tell you, man,
I've been watching the show.
I am sort of embarrassed
to admit it. I never saw it."
I was like, "Oh,
don't be embarrassed,
but I'm glad
you're enjoying it now."
It's better
than getting a text like,
"Hey, I finally saw your show,
and I don't get it, man.
I don't, uh --"
-[ Laughs ]
That's so good.
Hey, I want to talk
about your movie.
'cause you know
I love a good rom-com,
and I do love a good love story,
and I love -- I'm Irish.
so I do love good shots
of Ireland anytime I can see it.
"Wild Mountain Thyme,"
T-H-Y-M-E.
-Then, Jimmy,
if you love those things,
this movie is for you.
-It was for me. I loved it.
Dude, I love Jamie.
I love Emily.
I go, and then, I get Jon Hamm
in there, as well.
I go, Christopher Walken?
-Hey -- Yeah, I'll up the ante.
How about a little Chris Walken
for you?
-[ Stammers ] Come on.
How was it to hang out in
Ireland with Christopher Walken?
-I will tell you the greatest
story. I did not --
This is secondhand. This is from
John Patrick Shanley,
the director and writer
of the film.
But he would say Chris was
so enamored of Ireland,
where he had never been
his whole life --
It was his first time.
My first time in Ireland,
his first time in Ireland --
that he would just
sit in his room
and stare out the window
at the cows,
and then he would
make up stories
about what the cows
were thinking.
-[ Chuckling ]
-Very, very detailed stories.
And let me tell you, they were
not pleasant thoughts.
-Wow, interesting.
-He was convinced
that the cows were very sinister
and were probably up to no good.
And I was kind of like --
-You can't
turn your brain off, man.
-No. I mean, that is
peak Walken right there.
There's only one Chris Walken.
And any time
you get to spend with him
is time that you just
absolutely treasure.
I didn't have a lot of scenes
with him,
but I got to spend
a couple dinners with him.
And I would just find myself,
like, smiling and nodding
and just having
the greatest time.
Such a lovely man.
-Just the air in Ireland.
Just everything, and you go --
Even if it's --
-Holy moly.
And you know, like --
We shot every inch of it.
It's so lush and beautiful.
And we were there
in September, October,
so it was kind of rainy.
But then it would just be, like,
rainbows everywhere.
You're like,
"Are you kidding me?
Like, come on, Ireland.
Like, we get it. We get it."
-"We get it."
-"We don't need 40 rainbows
to, like, hammer the point."
It's a hat on a hat on a hat
on a leprechaun on a hat
with a lucky charm
and then like two more hats.
-It's the greatest.
-Ah, it was so beautiful.
It was so beautiful.
-Do you want to set it up,
or did I set it up already just
saying that it's a love story
and --
-It's the most beautiful,
honest, sincere love story
without a trace
of cynicism or snark,
and it's the perfect antidote
to everything about 2020.
How's that?
-Ah, I love it.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Jon Hamm and Emily Blunt
in "Wild Mountain Thyme."
Take a look at this.
-I mean, I'm not so sure
about love,
but marriage is
a practical partnership --
who's gonna take out the trash,
that kind of thing.
-What marriage?
-Do you want to be married?
-Is that a proposal?
-No.
I mean in general,
do you want to be married?
-I suppose.
-Me, too.
Anthony, however, I don't think
he's the marrying kind.
-How would you know?
-Because you were right there.
You were right next door,
and nothing happened.
-I'm not next door now.
-No, you are not.
And I find that very promising.
-More with Jon Hamm
after the break.
Come on back, everybody!